[Musik]
mit dem garten mit den köpfen das
drittgrößte werden ich lebe gerne so
will ich weiß dass all das half nichts
um luca toni küchler hatte einst keine
ahnung von gärten
doch jetzt ist der selbstversorger und
lebt in einer kommune den traum einer
anderen gesellschaft wie du dich
fürsorge und war es dass bestimmte
chance haben der landesweiten
zukunftsgestalter das entscheidende tor
und das ist eigentlich sollten also dass
mehr versicherte zwar dass wir vor einer
woche oder husten vorhanden ist
ponys lebensphilosophie heißt
permakultur damit hatte er sein
persönliches glück gefunden wie er nun
mit dieser permakultur eine randregion
zum glück verhelfen will
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
wolbeck berg im emmental 1000 meter über
nähert
ronja und silvan sind hier oben geboren
es ist ende sommer der letzte hort im
jahr wintervorrat für die kleintiere die
schafe und kaninchen toni küchler
arbeitet teilzeit daheim und 60%
auswärts hinaus gestoppt
der selbständige umwelt
naturwissenschaftler hat sich für ein
sagen wir mal finanziell eher
unrentables leben entschieden
ihm geht es ums große ganze die natur
und eine lebenswerte zukunft
seit er mitte 20 die philosophie der
permakultur entdeckte lässt ihn das
nicht mehr los eine art gegenmodell zur
unbegrenzten globalisierung was jede
permakultur halten sehen wichtiger teil
ist wirklich manager wieder
zurückzubringen und landwirtschaft wurde
das aber wieder mehr von hand gemacht
wird also wieder mit der kultur entstand
rund um die landwirtschaft das ist wie
wenn ich irgendwo mitten anschaut wird
man das irgendwo zu sein wir haben eine
große tisch sitzt erste schritt folgen
und lehrt bezieher geknüpft
simon die frau von toni ist vor 13
jahren mit gezogen
eine städterin vom zürichberg die mit
landwirtschaft so gar nichts am hut
hatte ganz ganz viel zum
zum lernen und zum studienverlauf das
haus gestoßen dass einführungsrunde
ausgeschrieben und ag zürich als spd
oder der familie besessen hat und das in
der gruppe a vor juventus steht die
klappe und seiner kritik nicht allein
die idee der permakultur entstand in den
70er jahren in australien ihr
gründervater ist bill morrison heute ist
es eine weltweite stetig wachsende
bewegung menschen auf der suche nach
einem ganzheitlichen nachhaltigen
lebensstil moderne technologie inklusive
die organizer adamek berg ist eine art
lehrstätte für permakultur männern und
frauen von überall her begegne ich hier
für kost und logis wollen sie anpacken
während wochen oder gar monaten wie
diese beiden denen das ist meine erste
erfahrung mit biologischer
landwirtschaft und gartenbau
als ich hierher kam wusste ich da muss
ich bleiben
marc opelt nicht gehört wie simon und
toni zu denjenigen die das ganze jahr
auf dem wallberg leben auch er verdient
sein geld im wesentlichen aus herz für
alles und jeden scheint man hier zeit zu
haben
schnelllebig komme ich mir dabei vor
dass ich relativ physisches der
unmittelbare arbeit mit mit die
lebensgrundlage indem wir versuchen
möglichst viel größere eigene
nahrungsmittel produzieren möglichst
viel vor unserer energie selber herz
stelle die berufen zum lämmer und und
sehr nah ich hatten die an an die uhr
kreis läuft des lebens sie das fühlt
sich für mir sehr stimmig und richtig
man folgt keinem kourou will nicht
aussteigen sein und trotzdem eine
botschaft haben sie sehr wohl die
bamberger all das was was passiert in
der welt etwas gefühl hat etwas was
nicht gut und die straßen antwort darauf
seid aber hier schaffe man im ganz
kleinen aktiv- dass man konflikte zu
verhindern
konkret würde das dann beim speiseplan
heißen eigenes oder lokales essen kommt
auf den tisch so ganz konsequent sei man
aber längst nicht immer sagt mir toni
ich versuche einfach da eigentlich linie
die entscheidung so gut wie möglich zu
achten
ich glaube dass ich glaube dass habe
sagte das ist nicht ideologisch
unten im tal in trubschachen hat toni
krinner sein planungsbüro
ein wenig in die schuhe schieben was
macht jetzt der vater das ist schon aus
erfahrung denn da für sie oder für mich
eine klare luft aus
bei seiner arbeit bewegen sich auf
dünnem eis meint toni was am ende des
tages bei seinen projekten herauskomme
sei oft ungewiss
sicherheiten im herkömmlichen sinn
scheint es in seinem leben nicht zu
geben
ständige veränderung und anpassung als
lebensprinzip getreu dem permer
kulturellen motto die welt vor der
haustür verwenden ist sein wirkungsfeld
in erster linie die region
alternativ strom aus der gegend hat er
initiiert und sein neuestes projekt soll
das dorf belieben besichtigung vor ort
mit interessierten und dem
gemeindepräsidenten aufstellen dankt ich
dass man zweimal vom wieder erwachten
die prüferin bei hände ging es also bis
quasi zum werk soja und nachher habe ich
ja einen hammer das hosted da würden
teil wird auto zu gehören und hinten los
das puder rouge wo mitarbeiter typen
sowie der trauer werden auch in
stuttgart nichts land wo man zum
beispiel können die besucher zum schluss
habe sich das für selbstversorger also
weltweit die gärtnerei ich habe
vorstellen vielleicht erlebt hat die 2g
ifa - li bewundert und angst davor dass
da etwas neues oder bis 14 runden kein
zurück schaffe ich nicht aufpasse
schönste dorf aus anderen hauses
schönste auf mich sehr erotisch große
straße dorf das ist nicht einfach leute
zu bringen und das ist jetzt möglich
keit oder mit dem projekt die verbindung
mit mitte landwirtschaft und und wohnen
der stadt nicht nachhaltig es ist sehr
viel schwieriger verdammt räume sehr
verrückt wie viele randregionen kämpft
auch trubschachen seit jahren gegen die
abwanderung trotz stattlicher anzahl
arbeitsplätze in industrie und gewerbe
steht viel wohnraum leer
mehr greifen sie zur zone war für die
region
das ist bitter jetzt ev mit harz dem
nachwuchs ein volvo kämpft 40 meter
beschluss habe die zugezogenen wissens
opera metall her ist das ist nur traurig
das einsätzige niedersachsen werde ganz
sicher ist und dann das also auch so wie
es ja gleich bei der begrüßung und ist
solidarisch usa traditionell eher so
dass ich gute bezog das attribut auch
leicht aber da habe sie schon lange
engagiert
sollte dann der einst diese permakultur
genossenschaft siedlung gebaut werden
dann natürlich mit holz aus der region
toni hat da schon vorgespurt also
grundsätzlich wetter mit 211 ominöse
machen
platz kranjec toni arbeitet mit einer
zimmerei zusammen sie auf eine bauweise
umgestellt hat je mehr aus dem holz der
gegend macht geht der größte über
einfach aus um verarbeitet und dann 1000
die gute ganze workshop für gespräche im
auto des verlages bezugsfertige
aufgebaut und die wirtschaft dringt
massivholz mehrfach geschichte ohne leim
und mehrzahl verdübelt wird zu fettig
wänden verarbeitet
so kommt mehr als nur bestes holz zum
zug
das ist schlechter qualität das ist ein
system das ist die große mengen
gebrauchtwagen für diese produktion
braucht es neue maschinen ein riesen
hosenlupf sei das gewesen sagte
zimmermann
sony hatte bei der neuorientierung der
firma seine finger mit im spiel
[Musik]
dass ich das bin
[Gelächter]
das finde ich habe ganz schön dass es
produkt oder lügt wie überhaupt die mit
ms office sich das nicht aus berg ruft
und doch sagt mir dass es gibt aber
nicht so hoch ist die disziplin mit toni
die meisten fehler einfach
wirtschaftlicher mehr im vordergrund
dass man wird hier die wahl der beta des
holzhof wenn er auch die mehrzahl
australien begonnen
wirtschaftlich muss es auch bei den
bambergern sein
ich staune aber mit wie wenig das geht
60000 franken einkommen braucht die
familie von simon und toni pro jahr
hier wird beinwell salbe für den verkauf
gemacht
das spielt etwas geld in die
gemeinschaftskasse hatte dass man jedes
mit hand und fuß und hand wie zb sb mit
der woche geben das indeca waschmaschine
hand vorhand viele hände für viel arbeit
rund bedürfnisse werden quasi kostenlos
gedeckt
durch zahlreiche wechsel hat diese
kommune schon erlebt und sich immer
wieder neu zusammen gewürfelt nicht nur
schmerzfrei
ich stelle es mir durchaus schwierig vor
seinem platz hier immer wieder zu finden
was sie aus partnerschaft betrifft dass
wir nicht jeden tag nur ist zwei hand
oder sind dass man immer nur eine
größere geführt sind und wir sind eine
größere könntest du ja oder gar nicht so
bedingungslos vom vom anderen ab haut
oder also wahltrend gerade nicht zu
hause
fazit aller kalus herzlich haben wir
dazu private mieter weg und das kannst
du musst du musst du natürlich hätte
auch wende sich wieder nach halt nicht
so fest voneinander
ob das für alle immer so einfach ist mit
der austauschbarkeit in der gemeinschaft
es ist tag der offenen tür auf dem
bergwerk asse aus der ganzen schweiz
sind sie ins emmental gepilgert
und was eigentlich das prinzip ist mit
und mitunter rote flagge mit der pflanze
flagge in erster linie also wir
versuchen das kompostieren so viel boden
auf bauer für pflanze dass sie sich mit
dem haben was sie braucht und das sind
auch anrufer und die einzelne pflanze
klage du das auch linden wird alles ohne
künstlichen dünger und ohne chemie
aber ich bin auf dem land aufgewachsen
und das ist krank sie türen nach oben
und tassen und eigentlich hätte er nie
kempo für dünger und es hat etwas von
früher
und doch geht die permakultur weiter mit
den mitteln der zeit anleitungen oder
gütesiegel gibt es keine von der natur
lernen sich einordnen ins system immer
nach dem grundsatz tragen sorge zu erde
und den menschen und teile werden also
es ist nicht immer richtig ist dass das
zusammengehört wie zu jedem anderen
abend dass man lange schon zwischen eu
und dem verzweifle das rosa oder
zähflüssig im august habe sich das jetzt
vom finanziellen oder dass wir sind eine
ganz andere um familie und das ist nicht
ganz bestimmt
vor dem hintergrund der fall also das
wird zum beispiel dass ein trainer auch
für mit 721 geht dass ich das ist
natürlich auch mit der unterstützung von
trixi und und damit bildung und mit all
dem was wir was mitnehmen
[Musik]
beim projekt der wohnsiedlungen
trubschachen hat sich mittlerweile
einiges getan
herzlich willkommen zu der
gründungsversammlung vor der
genossenschaft oder wahnsinnig viel
interesse für ein projekt bei dem
manches noch unklar ist die finanzierung
steht zwar aber ob es zum verkauf des
grundstückes kommt ist zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch offen
trotzdem wird an diesem abend
entschieden wie das eben aus der taufe
gehobene kind heißen soll
außerdem hatten die klassische oft
sonnenhaus wort das sie wirklich glaube
dass ich mir interessiert winter sieht
gesellschaftlicher wandel der natur
[Musik]
was macht sie nämlich nicht stückzahl
probieren es mit wunderbaren diese für
ältere herr mit großen oder merken dass
wir dieses ziel ist allerdings dass sie
ja also ich froh dass ganz gut findet
drucksache ziemliches loch war heißt
mediterrane frau geht geht das gibt es
das schwierige situation
und was meint toni der realist
vielleicht komme bei solch einem
riesenprojekt alles ganz anders
die meisten praktikanten entdeckt thomas
der däne ist doch da die gemeinschaft
auf dem wallberg plant das nächste jahr
sechs monate im voraus ist jeweils klar
ob grundlegende veränderungen anstehen
[Musik]
und wenn auch alles scheint im fluss
im besten permakultur allen sinnen
selbst funktionierendes system und wir
überlegen die jahre oder ich glaube sie
kam das fahrzeug machen
[Gelächter]
also ich bin positiv überrascht
[Musik]